forced adoption practices predate
Devolution in Wales but they continue to
affect those who experience them parents
children and wider family members
for many the feelings of loss grief
anger and pain remain
the time when these adoptions took place
many of the women were young vulnerable
and experiencing personal crises
they were not always informed of any
legal rights to look after their child
themselves or provided with the help
that they needed to do so
some were made to feel inadequate
immoral and undeserving when it came to
raising their own babies
adoption was put forward as the only
option because of a lack of Financial
and other support and the stigma
associated with illegitimacy and
motherhood out of wedlock
and even now many of those affected find
extremely difficult to open up and talk
about the lifelong heartbreak they've
kept to themselves for fear of still
being judged
the hurt endured by these historical
practices extend beyond the birth
mother's relationship with her child
some children who were adopted in these
circumstances have suffered a lifetime
of insecurity and anxiety despite being
loved and cared for by their adoptive
parents
some have an ongoing feeling that a part
of them is missing and continue to
question why their birth parents didn't
look after them and bring them up
themselves
the grief associated with not knowing
who they are is common amongst these
children and relates to loss of identity
lack of information about their Origins
origins of both birth parents and for
many including the children of ethnic
minority parents a loss of their wider
cultural and ethnic background
while the trauma of forced adoption has
been well documented from a mother and
child's perspective the impact on the
father is often forgotten
those fathers were generally disregarded
and blamed for corrupting innocent girls
they had little or no say in what
happened to the baby after birth leaving
them feeling helpless and unable to
support their partners
they very often became the Forgotten
characters whose voices were ignored I
therefore want to acknowledge fathers
experiences when it comes to these
historical practices too
these practices were unethical immoral
and May in some cases have been illegal
and I want to put on record today my
profound sympathy for all those affected
by historic forced adoption
regardless of the societal pressures or
the social norms of the day
such inhumane practice is should never
have been an acceptable part of our
society in Wales
the harm done to these individuals is
great
but as a government we owe them every
chance to live the rest of their lives
as free from trauma and torment as
possible
we cannot change what has happened but I
can provide assurances that adoption
legislation and practices have been
significantly improved since
adoption is now only considered when all
other options have been fully explored
services are designed to help those
families stay together whenever that is
possible and when it is not adoption
provides children with safety stability
and the opportunity to thrive
and I would like also to acknowledge and
put on record the important contribution
adoptive parents continue to make on
behalf of children by taking them into
their homes and into their hearts and we
the Welsh government are grateful for
them for providing the love and support
that all children need Dion thank you
now as a government we are listening to
people's experiences and stories to
ensure the right support and
professional counseling for those
affected is readily available
the national adoption service has
developed a web page specifically those
affected by historical adoptions this
provides a host of information relating
to adoption support and counseling
access direct records and intermediary
services
it will also be able to sign post
individuals to other services including
peer support and advocacy groups Welsh
government funded post-adoption support
services and at the long-standing
non-government service providers
my officials have already begun to work
alongside the national adoption service
to consider the issues outlined within
the joint committee's report and develop
Support Services which will address the
specific needs of those affected by
these practices
we've recently held a consultation event
involving birth parents affected by
historic adoption practices
this provided a safe space to listen and
hear views and to inform our service
development
we will continue to engage with these
mothers as we develop our services
officials and the national adoption
service have started scoping the
regulatory changes that could be
introduced in Wales to support the
issues related to the shortage of
councilors able to provide post-adoption
support alongside considering our
intermediary services
we're also committed to fully exploring
with those affected the key challenges
they face with regard to adoption
records and we're currently scoping what
an improved National access to record
service for those affected by these
historical practices could look like in
Wales
as we Face future challenges we will
remember the lessons of family
separation and continue to protect the
fundamental rights of children and the
importance of their right to be cared
for by a parent
that is why as part of our work to
radically reform Children's Service in
Wales we are committed to continuing to
develop services that can support
vulnerable families to stay together
I would like to complain convey my
deepest sympathy and regret to all those
affected that due to society failing you
you've had to endure such appalling
historical practices in Wales and for
this the Welsh government is truly sorry
guys
and could I firstly thank you Deputy
Minister for bringing forward today's
statements on historical adoption
practices which follows the joint
committee on human on the human rights
inquiry into the experience of unmarried
women and their children who were
adopted during the 1950s 1960s and 1970s
as you mentioned in your statement
Minister many historical adoption
practices were unethical immoral and in
many cases illegal in addition to this
these practices continue to impact many
who experience them and also um for many
the feelings of loss grief anger and
pain remain
this really was an utterly horrific
situation and one that should not have
occurred I must never happen again in
light of this Minister and on this side
of the chamber the Welsh conservative
senath group would like to identify with
the apology that has been made by the
Welsh government today
many people
um will will be able to sympathize with
the devastating impact that these um
forced adoptions caused
um I'm being a father of two children
myself
um I um it would be a pain
um that would be uh never-ending
um I'm Deputy Minister if I may I'd like
to raise a few questions with you
regarding um your statement today
um you said Deputy Minister that many
who underwent adoption practices were
not always informed of any illegal um
sorry legal rights to look after their
children themselves or provided with the
help um that they needed to do so of
course this is extremely concerning
Deputy minister so could I ask what what
work has now been undertaken to ensure
all those liaising with adoption
practices are informed of their legal
rights and secondly Deputy Minister you
say some children who were adopted in
these circumstances have suffered a
lifetime of insecurity and anxiety
despite being loved and cared for cared
for by their adopted parents in light of
this Minister what further work is being
carried out to ensure those who have
been impacted are fully supported and
finally Deputy Minister you mentioned
that a consultation event was recently
held involving birth parents affected by
historic adoption practices
um could I welcome this consultation and
ask if any initial assessment has been
made from this initial consultation and
whether any more will be carried out in
the near future and to reiterate what I
stated at the beginning of my response
I'd like to thank you for bringing
forward today's statement and I
reiterate our support for your actions
this afternoon thank you
and thank you for associating yourself
with the apology that I've given on
behalf of the Welsh government today as
is very much um appreciated
um obviously um you'll raise some very
important points uh we are working to
make sure that um children who are
adopted now and mothers of children who
adopted parents of children who are
adopted are fully aware of their um
legal rights and have the opportunity to
have the support and professional advice
and that they need adoption is as I said
in my speech now I've considered as the
last the last resort and that every
effort is made to keep children with
their families and to give support to
them at home and that is why we've got
the program as you know about of trying
to radically transform children services
that we've put in so much support to try
to keep children in their families and
in their communities and the point about
adopted children often experiencing and
insecurity and and anxiety something
that has been well recorded and we do
put in resources for post-adoption
support uh there's a considerable amount
of post-adoption support now going on in
Wales
um in fact I think in the barometer
where it's listed how um how different
parts of the UK
um are are managing their services
um Wales does score very high in terms
of the support it gives them to families
in Wales so we do have specifically uh
post-adoption services that are dealing
with the trauma because I think in the
past we thought right you have an
adoption order and that's it and
everybody lives happily ever after but
obviously that's not true I mean it's a
it is basically a lifetime really of
coming to terms with a trauma that may
have happened before and for dealing
with the feelings that have resulted as
a result of you know of of not knowing
sometimes what um what um your Origins
and were and also the
um stress that has been left with the um
the mothers and the other people
involved who whose babies
won't give up for adoption they were
taken
and then finally the consultation we
have set up a consultation Group which
is made up of people with lived
experience of of these practices and we
hope that this would be will form a
permanent group that we can work with so
that our responses will be geared to
what um is wanted and what is needed so
we want to be sure that we bring people
who are aware of what actually happened
um you know to them and the effect this
had on their lives so that we can
respond in the strongest way possible
thank you very much for the support
hello
thank you Lord and thank you to the
deputy Minister for this very important
statement
this
is something that forces to reflect on
the importance of having our own Senate
here in Wales that we can put right some
of the wrongs of the past and to give
that important apology they are small
world words and easy to say but it's
so difficult when people have had to
fight so hard and we know that the UK
government continues to be of the view
that
there isn't a need for this kind of
apology but it's important that we do
acknowledge what has happened in the
past and I'd like to associate myself
and play Camry with your apology and
your comments today this is an important
moment an important statement and I hope
it'll give some comfort to those people
who are suffering trauma and ongoing
suffering it won't put right what has
been done it's not going to remove that
trauma but certainly having that
recognition that they deserve an apology
is very important indeed and I'm pleased
and proud to see this happening in our
national Parliament
certainly it was an important moment to
see Scotland doing this and there are a
number of lessons to be learned I'm sure
we will have all met people
who have suffered because of this cruel
policy and it was cruel it was cruel to
everyone involved and it's very
important that things are different now
and
it's good to have an assurance from the
deputy Minister the things are now
different and that we have learned those
lessons but certainly this is something
that we need to keep a close eye on in
an ongoing Manner and to ensure that all
necessary support is available to any
family or individual in that difficult
situation
the one thing I would like to see and I
saw in your statement and I would like
some clarity in terms of the support
that will now be available because
clearly
hearing the apology could actually bring
up all of these feelings in many many
people and you refer to counseling now
the Scottish government had declared 145
000 pounds specifically to provide
specialist support and counseling for
those affected so may I ask whether
there is specific funding in place in
order to support this or how would you
intend to ensure that that support is
available because clearly many people
will be listening to your statement
today and would be good to have an
assurance in terms of how they can
access that support so that's my only
question but thank you for this as I say
it's an important moment for us NF and
I'm very proud to see the Welsh
government doing this today
um thank you very much for that
contribution and for the association of
my country with the apology I'm very
grateful um for that and I think it's
really important that we are united
across the whole of the Senate um in
supporting this apology and we you know
we do hope that this apology in itself
will bring some relief to the people who
I know have campaigned for so long in
order to get an apology and it is good
that we have Devolution and we can make
that decision here and we've decided
that we must formally apologize
um to the people who have let us know
what it has meant to them all these
years these historical practices that
were were so um was was so poor and I
think um health birken is absolutely
right in saying that this was a cruel
policy and it's um we should um you know
recognize that now and it is different
now we have learned lessons but we do
have to keep a watching brief and seeing
exactly what is happening and I hope
that we have got that built into the
system in order to keep that watching
brief in terms of what we will be able
to provide
um there is a shortage of counselors and
we are looking at ways of perhaps
changing the regulations in order to be
able to get to more counselors than
available but we are doing all this in
consultation with the group that we've
set up and so I'm not really able to say
that we will do something specific or
spend a specific amount of money because
we want to do it co-productively with
people who have actually got the lived
experience and as I said in response to
the earlier question
um Wales has got a good record on
post-adoption support now because we
have put considerable resources into it
so we do have places to direct people
but we do hope that by making this
public apology G by making it as public
as we possibly can that it will reach
those people who haven't actually been
in the campaigns but be have been you
know having this um secret you know for
years and years and not being able to
have the opportunity to express it so I
hope we are going to reach some of those
people and obviously we will have to
respond
um to any requests that we actually get
but we're I think the apology in itself
is very important but I know that it
does lead to the need for to do other
things
thank you very much to your leadership
on this matter
thank you very much for your leadership
on this really painful matter reflecting
on when I was a young woman in the 60s
and 70s I can genuinely say I did not
know about this I was a very
misbehaving radical woman had I known
um I would have done something about it
instead I was campaigning for women's
rights to choose
these women had no choice and it is
certain that they these practices were
unethical and moral and almost certainly
an abuse of their human rights
um I think we have to ask ourselves why
how is it that these organizations that
suppressed this information
from The Wider public for for some 30
years it was really only in the 80s and
90s that these issues started to be
aired in public and what were the
bystanders to the all that was going on
doing why did they not speak out
these are things we absolutely have to
ask ourselves
in terms of the mitigation that you are
endeavoring
um to rectify in relation to the harm
done to these women and and
with mothers and fathers as well as
their children it seems to be absolutely
urgent that people need to meet their
parents before they die and therefore it
is essential that we accelerate the
process of enabling people to see their
records and given every help to try and
track down their relatives so I heard
you say that you were thinking of
changing the regulations Hallelujah
let's do that because these people have
got to have some justice some closure on
what is an appalling event that will
have dogged them for all their lives
I thank her Jenny Rathbun for those
contributions um The Joint Committee on
human rights uh if um you read their
report it does give some of the um
history of what has happened and how it
happened
um so that is very worth um reading and
we are starting to look at where whether
we could have a Wales wide way of
getting access to records because we do
hear some quite distressing stories
about the difficulty of getting access
to records of how it often takes them a
long time and the support is not always
there for when people actually do access
those records so we are certainly um
looking at that
and with um new Adoption practices we
are trying to ensure that adoptive
um young people and children are able if
it is sought all possible if they are
adopted to keep contact with their first
families
um because
um Having You Know spoken and known many
um adoptive young people they do want to
have that um link and they if we're able
to build it in in a more natural way
right from the beginning if it's not
possible for the children to live at
home with their families and adoption is
the best option if we can build in
adoption with contact with their first
families I think that is what we are
moving towards and I think this is quite
common in some other countries much more
common than it is here because we want
to move away from the situation where
um you know everything is done in a
cloak of secrecy and where it is
possible we want that contact to be
there so we don't have the situation of
people you know striving to make contact
with their um parents and not being able
to reach them so I think there are a lot
of practical things we can do that will
make it much easier for people in this
situation
and I'm you know we are absolutely
committed in the Welsh government to do
it all we possibly can and to relieve
the utter distress that has been caused
by these practices that took place
some years ago Jane Dodds
I'd like to pay tribute to those people
affected by this absolutely abhorrent
practice I pay tribute to the Poise and
dignity that you have all brought to
this debate in this discussion
and I'm sure we all humbly stand here
um really in all of you but also in
shame of what happened in the past
as leader of the Welsh liberal Democrats
and as chair of the Cross party group on
on children I associate myself with the
apology and I thank you for that I can
see how important it is to this
government with the first Minister here
in the Schaumburg and many members of
the cabinet as well associating
themselves with the Welsh government and
the Welsh people's position
on apologizing to those people affected
I cannot imagine the horrors that you
went through and I thank you that you
brought this to our attention and I
thank you that as survivors of this we
need to be constantly reminded of what
has happened in the past and how we can
improve it for the future thank you
thank you very much Jane for associating
the liberal Democrats with this um
apology and so that means that all the
parties in the chamber are thoroughly
behind us this apology
um so
I think that um this is just obviously
the beginning of the work and that we're
going to do on this issue but I think it
is very important um you know that we
finally um acknowledge that uh what
happened to those young women
um those who you know so many years ago
that we don't forget that and we don't
forget
um the terrible upset they went through
in terms of having you know having a
baby born to you wanting to keep it and
having it taken away from you and it's
being accepted as being the norm of the
time we must never never ever let
anything like that happen again and I'm
very pleased that um you know the Welsh
government is able to apologize today
and commit itself to doing all we
possibly can in the future to help
and I like Jane uh went to
express my
admiration for The Bravery that the
women who have brought this forward have
demonstrated because that's not easy and
um and it and and it was necessary
that's the issue and we're talking about
50s 60s and 70s we're not really talking
that long ago my children were born in
the 70s
and I cannot and I was a young mother
myself I cannot imagine
the pain and the heartache that those
women were going through I had a friend
who did go through that and she never
got over it ever and she didn't know
where her child was and how that child
was faring and her parents her parents
thought they were doing the right thing
because the stigma that she would have
experienced so they believed was greater
than the loss of her child of course
they were wrong but they did it for the
right reasons she told me her story many
decades ago about loving her son about
knitting things so that they could go
with him about buying toys and about the
huge wrench the loss when that child
left the room for the last time and she
lived with that and so I I knew about it
really from the 80s so I don't think you
know that
Society served anybody well here because
it wasn't just the mothers and the
fathers that have been mentioned but it
was the whole family the family who were
forced in a way to do what they thought
was the right thing for their daughters
and all the stigma that went with that
and of course the state was involved the
state could have helped they could have
supported financially if State chosen to
do that instead is stigmatizing young
women and sometimes not always young
women but just women who weren't married
who didn't fit a norm so I commend you
today and everybody in here will support
you in giving that apology what we can
do moving forward for those women and
their children and there will be
grandchildren now as well is hugely
important
yeah
your choice um for those um words and I
think Joyce does remind us that this was
not long ago really when you've happened
when this happened and you were talking
about the 80s um so it's um not very
long ago at all and also to remind us
that there are grandchildren so there's
a whole mass of people you know who are
have been affected by this and the
effects will go on for a long time so
once again thank you very much for the
support given here um in the center for
today and thank you above all to those
people some of whom are here with us in
the gallery today for campaigning and
bringing bringing this to the attention
of of us of the public of the government
and once again the Welsh government is
deeply sorry